willkommen zurück hierbei bild live und
man muss die frage stellen hat putin die
welt ausgetrickst hat der kreml chef nur
so getan als würde er den krieg nicht
wollen die usa die bahn jetzt ganz klar
russland sucht nur nach einem vorwand
für einen angriff auf die ukraine und
die welt die blickt jetzt auf die
münchner sicherheitskonferenz dort
kommen alle mächtigen politiker zusammen
zu markus söder so markus söder kommen
sie als er begrüßt dort us-vizepräsident
in kandahar ist aber russland russland
fehlt nicht meine vertreter aus 53 ist
da der herr ist hier die bilder von
gestern abend ist angekommen nimmt teil
an diesem treffen der mächtigen und
natürlich auch ukraines präsident
selensky ist ja er hat die kriegsangst
seines landes mit im gepäck denn dort in
der ukraine bereitet man sich vor bild
vize paul ronzheimer ist in der ukraine
hat auch in den vergangenen tagen so
wenske begleitet bevor dieser nach
münchen reiste und berichtet von dort wo
man sich bereit macht freiwillige üben
das schießen um sich zu verteidigen paul
ronzheimer ist uns jetzt genau von dort
zugeschaltet paul wasser liebste dort
gerade in diesen stunden in diesen
minuten die welt nach münchen schaut und
putin schon längst sein eigenes ding
macht man hat in der ukraine dem kreml
machthaber ja sowieso nie so richtig
glauben geschenkt
patricia ich bin hier auf einem
truppenübungsplatz in kiew weil man
keinen normalen für das ukrainische
militär sondern hinter mir sind menschen
zivilisten die vorher nicht so viel mit
der waffe zu tun hatten und die jetzt
dabei sind hier zu trainieren auf diesem
platz und sich vorzubereiten falls es
ein einmarsch gibt falls es einen
einmarsch gibt wollen sie dann bereit
sein für die waffe und wollen bereit
sein zu schießen und wollen bereit sein
am ende trainiert zu sein gegen die
russische armee gab es diesen moment
dort wo du gerade bist du überhaupt so
wie hier in berlin so wie hier in
deutschland dass man kurz
durchgeschnauft hat und gesagt hat vor
allen dingen nachdem der kanzler olaf
scholz putin besucht hatte naja gut also
jetzt ist ein bisschen luft raus er
ziemlichen panzer ab gab es diesen
moment des durchschnaufens dort
überhaupt
diese momente ist durchschnaufen stehen
gibt es hier momentan nicht also die
menschen glauben nicht daran dass
irgendetwas ja in eine richtung gelaufen
ist also das wirklich wladimir putin an
ende
zurückziehen könnte sie sagen diese
kriegsangst die gibt es hier schon ganz
lange diese kriegsangst die ist
vorhanden in der ukraine und wenn ich
jetzt mal an ihr hinter mich schaue
hinter diese menschen die bereit sind
und sich jetzt vorbereiten und bereit
sind zu schicken und sagen wir wollen am
ende ihr land vertreten wollen am ende
bereit seien hier gegen russische
truppen kämpfen zu können aber natürlich
kein natürlich patricia wäre die
ukrainische armee der russischen armee
maximal unterlegen was ich mitbekommen
habe in dem gespräch im pcie lanes die
den 45 stunden lang ist dagegen konnte
oder mit ihm unterwegs sein konnte und
immer wieder gespräche mit ihm geführt
habe da ist die wut auf deutsch darin
groß dass eben kein rappen geschickt
wurden dass man waffen aus anderen
regionen bekommen hat sich aus
deutschland und da ist man wütend dass
die sicherheitskonferenz angeht da wird
man am ende auch noch stolz sprechen
wurde in residence sie hat zu mir gesagt
erst ein jahr oder folkigen nach einem
treffen gefragt am samstag unter telefon
treffen aber ich will ihm auch erneut
sagen dass die ukraine hilfe braucht
über das spricht ja gerade jetzt
zivilisten rüsten sich dort für den
krieg die greifen zur waffe obwohl sie
sonst damit überhaupt gar nichts zu tun
haben um sich zu verteidigen um ihr land
zu verteidigen was schildern wir diese
menschen
ja patricia das sind ganz
unterschiedliche menschen darunter
teilweise sind ist ich habe mit ihm
gesprochen der bauer da war vorher unter
gesagt er will sich jetzt hier an der
waffe trainieren doch eine frau sprechen
können die eigentlich hausfrau ist und
jetzt hier trainiert dazwischen sind
ehemalige militärs die früher schon
einmal in der armee gekämpft haben also
ist ein mix aus leuten aber sie alle
eint dass sie noch nie so sehr den ja
die die forderung gesehen haben und
tatsächlich das mussten dass es hier
verteidigung gibt also sie sehen
dringenden bedarf dann vier zivilisten
dabei sind um ihr land zu verteidigen
und sie sagen wenn putin kommt dann
reicht unser armee nicht aus und
deswegen müssen wir hier jetzt auf dem
truppenübungsplatz in einem ganz
normalen
freitagmorgen trainieren weil glauben
tatsächlich könnte es irgendwann los
geht paul ronzheimer in der ukraine sich
zivilisten für eine mögliche invasions
russlands jetzt rüsten hinter ihm in
diesen minuten paul vielen herzlichen
dank und die welt schaut weiter gebannt
nach münchen schaut was rauskommen
könnte an diesem tag in dem putin sich
im hintergrund längst bereit macht
offenbar für einen krieg manöver sogar
testet mit atomwaffen ja das macht er
jetzt gerade in diesen momenten so heißt
es das us außenministerium warnte ganz
klar besuchs in russland nach einem
vorwand um den krieg zu beginnen mann
hatte natürlich gehofft dass ein
russischer vertreter auch auf der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz erscheinen
möge das hat sich auch wolfgang
ischinger sehr gewünscht man hat aber
eine einladung abgelehnt dort also wo
sich jetzt in diesen minuten die
mächtigen der politik treffen wird
russland nicht mit am tisch sitzen